-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy and
Academy Award-winning
writer, director, and comedian
behind films such as
"Get Out," "Us,"
and "Wendell & Wild."
His critically-acclaimed
film "Nope"
is now streaming on Peacock.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend,
Jordan Peele, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back!
It is so lovely to
have you here.
Last time you were here,
I was lucky to have you
with the entire cast of "Nope."
-Yeah.
-This time I'm very happy
to have you to myself.
You know, we've known each other
for a very long time.
-Yes.
We've come some far way,
my old friend.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
We met each other about
20 years ago.
We worked for
an improv comedy theater
in Amsterdam called
Boom Chicago!
And I know we've talked
about that before,
but it's still, you know,
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I was lucky
enough to know you then.
I can't believe how incredible
your career has been since,
and it's really cool to be able
to sit here with you like this.
-And we had some wild times.
-We had some wild times.
-In Amsterdam.
-In Amsterdam, we did.
[ Laughter ]
Mostly legal.
Yeah, right?
-I mean, everything
is legal there.
That's the problem.
-Well, I was thinking because
there's a really cool thing,
which is the amusement park
in the film "Nope."
Jupiter's Claim.
-Mm.
-Is actually being recreated
at Universal Studios.
-Yes.
-One of the wilder times we had,
and more than once,
was we would go to
a Dutch theme park
called Efteling.
-Yes. "Elfland."
-Elfland, yeah.
You just translated the Dutch.
It's called "Elfland."
And it's a wonderful place.
-Yeah.
-And even though there's not
a sign outside that says
"Do drugs here"...
[ Laughter ]
...I always felt like
it was implied.
-It was implied.
-Yeah.
-And somehow accepted, like,
the staff would walk up to you
with shrooms
is kind of the feeling.
-Yeah, exactly.
They didn't have, like,
cotton candy.
Not, like, high-calorie
foods that American..
-Children running around
and they look like fawns.
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
-Dutch fawns.
-And it's interesting, because
the Dutch are a very --
very blunt people,
they're very honest.
They'll walk up to you and say,
"How nice to meet you.
I don't like your shirt."
You know?
They'll say things like that.
And I feel like there was
one moment
where you sort of
adopted that sort of tone.
-I think because we were
in the Dutch culture
and maybe I had
overserved myself.
I became very honest.
-To be fair, we had had
a long bacchanalia.
-Yeah.
-Of sorts. A long party.
And I remember you saying to
a group of us --
-Dear friends of mine.
-Dear friends.
Just straight up,
"I don't know, man.
I don't want to be here anymore.
I don't want to.
I'm tired of hanging out with
the people
I'm hanging out with."
[ Laughter ]
And we're just watching you
feel comfortable
telling us that, you know.
-It was a very supportive
group of people.
I think what had happened is,
I had gone to get a water
and I was standing in line,
and very amusement-park-y,
someone had won, like,
a stuffed lizard
and a child was holding
and the stuffed lizard
was looking at me.
-And you had a meltdown.
-And I had a moment
where I'm like,
"I gotta go."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And then we grow up.
-And then we grew up.
-And now we're...
-But I didn't know this, of all
these years I've known you,
I did not know that your first
major in college was puppetry.
-Yes.
-Wow.
I mean, it does feel like
the good first building block,
but what was the decision
to choose that?
-Well, yeah, so I went to
Sarah Lawrence College
in part because it was
mostly female.
-Mm-hmm.
-Then I immediately took away
my advantage
by declaring myself
a puppetry major.
[ Laughter ]
To balance things out.
-Yeah, right.
You don't want to
make it unfair.
-I don't want to make it unfair.
But no, I was in love --
I grew up and I loved
"The Nightmare Before Christmas"
growing up,
and how that film by
the great Henry Selick,
whom I've had the pleasure
of working with...
-Yeah, you just did a film,
"Wendell & Wild"
with Henry Selick.
-"Wendell & Wild," which is
the type of film that,
if I had seen when I was a kid
or if I was 12 years old,
I think it would have changed
the way I feel about
my place in the industry
and in puppetry.
And so, very proud of this film
and it's really --
it's wonderful, yeah.
-I think one of the cool things
is watching you get to
collaborate with people
that I know you've loved forever
and I've loved forever.
You're an EP on
this wonderful show,
"Hunters" is coming back
for a second season.
Al Pacino is one of the people
in "Hunters."
-Oh, yeah.
-I mean, a legend.
-Legend.
-How was your time
with Al Pacino?
-Well, admittedly brief.
I've been in the presence
of this man only briefly,
and he's hilarious.
I mean, first of all, you are
in the presence of a guy
who is essentially a made man in
terms of cool, forever.
-Yeah.
-And he an actor's actor.
He's the consummate actor.
And so he's, you know --
[ As Al Pacino ] "He's always --
He's fascinating."
[ Laughter ]
I don't really have
a good Pacino.
-Mine is very good,
I should warn you.
-Okay, yeah.
-Mine is based entirely on the
fact that he was nominated,
I believe maybe for "Hunters."
He was nominated for an award
in the first COVID year.
And my favorite thing that
happened during COVID
was seeing Al Pacino
in a Zoom room.
-Okay.
-Because even in that little box
where he didn't know
where to look
and it was not well-lit,
still the coolest dude
in the world.
-That's right.
-And so my new
Al Pacino impression
is entirely based on that.
You ready for it?
-Yeah, okay.
-[ As Al Pacino ]
"Hey, I'm in the Zoom room!"
[ Laughter ]
-That's good.
-I know, right?
[ Applause ]
-Thank you.
-Very good.
-Yeah, there was a moment there
in his career
where I feel like
he started chewing gum.
And he got a little Black.
[ Laughter ]
A little bit Southern,
a little bit Black.
And it was like he was
honing his Black --
'Cause from "Scarface,"
he already had us.
-Yeah.
-From Michael Corleone,
he already had us.
But I feel like he's committed
to his Blackness.
-And it's really fun
when somebody like that --
because they can make
those choices
and they've gone past the point
where anybody's gonna
go over and be like,
"Maybe just bring it --
Dial it back."
-He can get away with anything.
-He can just get away with it,
and so those people,
those icons, those legends,
those are the fun ones
to keep an eye on,
'cause you're like, "Never know
where this is gonna go."
-He could come in full-on
Foghorn Leghorn
and fool everybody.
-Yeah.
-But no, he's a genius.
And "Hunters," man.
The season is incredible.
Incredible cast.
I'm so proud of the show.
It's crazy and it's wild.
-That's great.
I want to ask you a bunch more
about "Nope."
We'll be right back
with more from Jordan Peele!